في هذه المنطقه من كهرمان مراش انتهت
عمليات انقاذ الناجين
وايضا انتهت عمليات ازاله الجثث المرحله
حاليا هي لاخذ عينات من هذه الاماكن من
هذه الابنيه لمعرفه مدى جودتها وجوده
بنائها كل بناء في هذه المنطقه يتم اخذ
عينه منه وتسجيل ذلك في ضبط بالنيابه
العامه وذلك لانها ستكون جزءا من
التحقيقات المستقبليه حول موضوع ما اذا
كانت شده الزلزال فقط هي التي تسببت
بالدمار ام ان سوء البناء هو ايضا عامل
ساهم في الدمار في كل مكان من هذه الاكوان
من الالقاب قصص وحكايات في كل مكان وتحت
كل حجر ذكرى
هنا احد الكتب ربما نستطيع ان نراه عنوان
هذا الكتاب
رحله لا نهايه لها يشبه هذا العنوان وضع
من كانوا هنا
والان هم باتوا بلا بيوت ربما مات من مات
ومن بقي باتا من دون بيوت هذه السياره
كانت يوما ما تعمل وكانت ربما سببا لرزق
لعائله للعائله التي كانت تملكها التجول
هنا في هذا هذه الاكوان من الانقاض ربما
احكي حكايه بعض الناس الذين كانوا موجودين
واضح ان هذه القطعه من الكرسي ايضا هي
كانت في يوم من الايام جزءا من حياه كان
اصحابها يعيشون هنا بامان قبل ان يضرب
الزلزال فجاه مظهر الانقاذ هذه كلها عباره
عن
تحوي اشياء من حياه الناس هنا هناك استطيع
ان ارى ربما قاروره كبيره للماء تستعمل
هذه القاروره في تركيا هنا تستعمل هذه
القاروره في تركيا في البيوت من اجل الشرب
مياه الشرب
قطعه من جهاز التدفئه كان في احد البيوت
كل هذه
الاجزاء من الانقاض هي كانت ربما قصصا او
تساهم في قصص للاشخاص طبعا الذين ماتوا
رحمه الله عليهم والذين بقوا هم الان في
رحله ربما كعوان الكتاب الذي رايناه رحله
لا نهايه لها حتى يتم
استقرارهم مجددا في منازل
تؤمنهم من زلزال قادم